Kevin Hart's whole family is in on the
Halloween spirit
yes they're all dressed up as minions
and when you think about it worked with
camp is kind of like working with a
minion you got that as a joke okay well
anyway he's completely out of control
just ask Bryan Cranston who stars with
Kevin the great new movie the upside
come in I'm like why would up day one we
hear baby loud I'm Byron and this is
exactly when I would get in return
don't your arms work they don't you can
move your mouth as can you was there
ever a time where you wanted to just you
wanted to break character and just jump
up and just growl yeah absolutely
what yeah oh man do not fall for their
squabbling act these two are actually in
a bromance up I think he's a great
talent he's funny as hell thank you he's
very handsome and these are the these
are the thoughts that I know he's
thinking about of me and because of that
because of that I grew to tolerate
except his presence I understand would
you maybe you say talent marina brian is
a paralyzed billionaire and kevin is the
ex-convict who becomes his caretaker you
are not qualified for this position
Nicole Kidman is Brian's assistant at
the premiere of her film boy erased she
sent this message i Kevin sending you
love she don't say Brian hi you behind
the cost
did you stop it shorted the doubt was
that was every team I don't know what
call is so cool I don't think she's that
great in the movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]